are we willing to elect someone as
president who has as their role model
somebody who acknowledges Lucifer the
last day of the RNC and looking back at
the past week there's really only one
thing to say this has all been one giant
kind of scary circus in reality Trump
chased off the establishment there's no
job no Romney not even Kasich the
governor of this state and there'd been
no speeches by former Republican
presidents
it's Trump's party and only his friends
RSVP'd except for one notable party
crasher
vote your conscience there's the clouds
like the delegates who say things like
this
we're not the party that's murdering 58
million babies in this country and
Republicans outside who say things like
this
and Republicans outside who say things
like this we in the media swarmed here
because we're part of the circuit too
but put us and the police together and
we outnumber the activists and the
delegates we're all waiting for
something and once in a while we get a
moment like this
or a little action when groups protest
the hate being spewed inside here's some
of the stuff that got the loudest cheers
I said Islamic extremist terrorism blue
lives matter in America so the take away
the whole thing's been overhyped but you
gotta cover the circus when it comes to
town in case anybody falls off the
tightrope